why have you started mapping out red
lines when before the front page of the
manifesto would have done as the measure
of your priorities in any posted ocean
situation because two reasons really I
think firstly it's become so obvious if
not to end Miliband and David Cameron
who is still robotically going around
saying they're going to win a majority
then no one's going to win an outright
majority so the first election I can
remember in my adult political career
when everyone knows that no one's going
to win before a vote has been cast and
then I think there's led lots of voters
to hold off from making a decision till
quite late in the day two is very
sensible keep us politicians sweating
but it's meant that I think voters quite
rightly demanding you like fixed points
and clear reassurances about what will
be delivered if they vote for this or
that party and that's why I think it is
right for me to say look we will not go
into government if the conservative
liberal parties impose cuts in the way
that they're planning on our education
system we will not go into government
unless the eight billion pounds is
provided to the NHS and we boost help
for people with mental health problems
we will not go into government unless
there are further tax cuts for people
who learn middle incomes you will never
spending pledges though that sounds like
a sort of bias no no way you're funny
enough she just dropped me exactly the
point where it doesn't involve spending
pledges which is to balance the books in
a timely way and to do so in a fair way
and actually that includes for instance
I'm quite open about it some tax
increases on dividends tax on capital
gains tax or a number of other measures
which only affect the very wealthiest
which make a real material contribution
to balancing the books and doing so
firmly but that's an extraordinary array
of policies contained in your existing
full red lines and that's practically an
entire government prose what we've
achieved in this government in five
years I'm constantly reminded of one
policy we were not able to put into
practice on tuition fees if you look at
the fact that's 75 percent of the
Liberal Democrat manifesto from the last
election made its way into the coalition
agreement and that everything from a
massive expansion of apprenticeships a
total liberal overhaul of the pension
system a revolution income tax so that
no one pays any income tax in the first
ten thousand six hundred pounds they
earn more money going towards the
education of
varta children childcare shared parental
leave lunches healthy lunches for little
toddlers at Primary School equal
marriage the list goes on that means I
have much much longer list than some of
the red lines that I'm setting out here
and interestingly if you look at the
other parties and we've just seen last
night David Cameron basically announced
the nation that the Conservatives and
you keep are now interchangeable because
while I'm saying that I think the
priorities for a lot of people in the
country are decent public services fair
tax cuts finishing the job of balancing
the books putting money into our
nurseries and schools and colleges David
Cameron's based announced the only thing
that conserve does care about is the
same things Nigel far you're willing to
bargain that away that's not not going
to be a red line what I said what I'm
saying to you is while Europe is
important and I'll make further
announcements over the weekend about
about two more red lines let me be very
clear I think I am much more in lying
the mainstream British public opinion
than the Conservatives are you keep our
but I don't think elevating the internal
kind of rancor about Europe in the
conservative party to the sole purpose
in life which is what David Cameron is
declared represents what people what
people want whether they are for or
against Europe above all they want a
government that is stable its strong
that it's fair that completes the job of
economic recovery does it fairly invests
in public services gives tax cuts to
people on low and middle income now look
other parties need to choose but since
you asked me about my red lines I just
contrast them with other parties of like
the Conservatives who I think a huge
tactical mistake on their behalf I've
now basically become interchangeable
with Nigel Farage is party in terms of
their stated read lines with best will
in the world no forecaster is projecting
you to have much over 30 MPs maybe 40 on
a good day how can that tail wag a much
larger parties dog as it were in terms
of setting the agenda on something like
tax your particular tax priority that's
not a big party why would they go with
your priorities they don't want to
though they have to agree to it and then
we don't enter into government it's very
simple so you're looking forward to
minority government
come to the opposition benches I
challenge other parties to disagree with
my view that it is right because we owe
it to the next generation that balance
the books in a timely fashion and to do
so fairly I challenge all the leaders to
explain to me why they think it's fair
to take billions of pounds out of
nursery schools or colleges like this I
challenge other parties to spell out as
I've spelt out our three-point plan to
put eight billion pounds of extra money
into the NHS by the next parliament I
challenge other parties why they would
disagree with my view that having
achieved this massive change in the tax
system so that no-one peddick pays an
income tax on the first ten thousand six
hundred pounds that they earn why anyone
would disagree that we go further and
ensure that no one pays any income tax
on the first twelve and a half thousand
pounds later if they disagree with those
things and they want to they want to
indulge themselves in other in other
things fine but the Liberal Democrats
will not enter into a government unless
it is in line with our instincts our
values and our key priorities it doesn't
sound like you're equidistant between
neighboring conservatives it sounds like
for obvious reasons perhaps that you
would prefer a continuation of the
current coalition with the Conservatives
no I am I'm entirely equidistant between
my dismay at George Osborne's hardline
punitive approach to imposing
ideologically inspired cuts on our
public services and making the
working-age Paul pick up the tab for the
mistakes made of the made by the bankers
against totally unfair as I am dismayed
by Ed Balls and Ed Miliband's economic
illiteracy who want to carry on
borrowing and borrowing pots of money
and failing to apologize for crashing
the economy in the first place I find
out if you are going to choose between
unfairness on the one hand and if
failure to balance the books on the
other I find available to choose when
you consider that it meant you you're
making a lot of statements now about the
legitimacy of various post-election
situations five years ago you made the
point about Gordon Brown losing votes
losing seats at a government in party
and basically had to go that is highly
likely to be your situation your
government party the moment you've lost
two-thirds of your vote share maybe half
of the MP
it's going to be something in that
region what legitimacy will you have to
determine what is the judgment in
opposed to let no one tells the Liberal
Democrats who leads the double Democrats
other than liberal democrats in deciding
whether the bit you go with the biggest
party of the second party you know do
you recognize that's not a
constitutional principle how can you
have a constitutional principle in the
country which doesn't have a
constitution I'm just spelling out
something flaming the obvious as a
politician who has got his ear close to
the ground about how people feel forget
pointy-headed constitutional lawyers
it's just as just so obvious if in an
election the British people they're the
boss they're the boss not constitutional
law it's you don't effectively the Prime
Minister grounds confident so how I
finish can I finish my explanation and
I've been entirely consistent about this
the run-up to the last election at the
formation of the coalition throughout
this Parliament another run up to this
election I just think it is a good
old-fashioned straightforward a
democratic principle that the party that
has got the greatest mandate from the
British people most votes the most seats
has got more wind in its sales than
anybody else even if it hasn't won an
outright majority would in the eyes of
the British public and they're the boss
not some not some Constitution academic
they're the boss that in the eyes of the
British public they would quite rightly
expect that that would be the party that
could first try and assemble a
government they might choose not to they
might choose not to reach out to other
parties other parties might not
reciprocate and other alternative
arrangements might need to be arrived at
but call me old-fashioned but I think in
a democracy surely the party that has
has got its nose in front of the others
even if it hasn't got an outright
majority has the right to try and
assemble a government this is very
important as it to be very clear there
are circumstances in which the leader of
a second-place party could be a
legitimate Prime Minister if the other
options have been exhausted only after
the other legitimate option i think the
chronometer peep chronology the steps
you take in a democracy particularly
after an uncertain outcome are really
important to the subsequent legitimacy
of any government that is full and this
is what I think there I sec so this sort
of clever clever pointy-headed
discussion battle is just misses you
cannot do anything which the British
people don't feel goes with the grain of
the instructions they've given to
politicians and if you leap
or bypass or try and somehow ignore the
the outcome in which one part is killing
are better than others even if it hasn't
got a majority I think you clearly
create trouble because people say we're
hang on a minute why don't you let that
party try and put a government but then
as I say they may not succeed and then
maybe out that alternative arrangements
may arise but as you know the point here
is that there may be an effort to dealer
gitam is the idea in any event forget
the sequencing of a government that's
arrived at where the leader of the
second-placed party becomes Prime
Minister you certainly work and if you
do if you don't take the steps in the
way that I've described because people
won't understand everybody the British
people are really pragmatic they really
are they then you know that very smart
they will get that the politicians might
have a sort of sort of might have so
cards dealt with them you know which
which require some grown-up discussion
between the parties and all I'm saying
is like the British people would expect
respectful of their wishes as expressed
in the ballot box through their votes
that the biggest party or the party with
the biggest mandate most votes the most
seats has the has the is given the
opportunity to try and assembly they
might not succeed but at least the
British people then accept whatever
ensues if first that parties being given
a chance to assemble a government and
you know I just find that so obvious
that I find it remarkable that a lot of
sort of I think slightly out of touch
and academic constitutionalists don't
see that one last question you must be
contemplating in this could be or last
week in your job no I look I mean I
don't mean I've said this throughout the
election campaign i will say at the
remaining days people always right off
the liberal democrats we always confound
the skeptics we always confound our
cretak critics we always confound this
cottage industry of pessimistic pundit
Ori I'm not being blase about it I'm
gonna be silly of course we've got a lot
of tough fights on our hands but we're
really good at campaigning we believe in
what we've done and guess what we might
be the smallest of the three main
parties at Westminster but we're now the
only party proudly standing up for the
politics of moderation the politics of
center ground common sense
decent politics in our country at a time
when the right has vacated the center
ground as David Cameron chases votes to
the right you get votes to the right and
as Edmund Miliband is being haunted by
the specter of Alex Salmond basically
dictating terms so if you want the
country to remain stable rather than a
shambles of the right or the left sort
of turning in on themselves the best way
to do that is to vote liberal Democrat
and I'm very confident that message will
bear fruit next week thanks for much as
i get those promises picture